tension mechanism is just a way to route
information between parts of the
sequence and that's the genius behind a
transformer layer-by-layer the routes
information to the correct place in the
sequence such that it understands the
entire thing at once
talk to your conference like I see
Melbourne herbs and getting the interest
in the research community comes the
pressure surpassed the previous AVR
[Music]
[Applause]
do you remember when GPT 2 was released
or indeed wasn't released because it was
too dangerous it had about 1.5 billion
parameters in it it was a transformers
language model it was trained on a
corpus of about 40 gigabytes of text but
it was highly curated fast forward one
year and Microsoft had just released a
new version pretty much of the same
model that has 17 alien parameters 18
billion doesn't matter it's a lot in the
olden days we had these static brittle
knowledge graphs they were handcrafted
he was incredibly onerous to create
these things but if we wanted to do
something like question and answering it
was the only way we could do it if we
wanted to say what year did we win the
second world war without some kind of an
ontology of information we couldn't
capture it these transformer
transductive language models that we
have you can pre train them on a large
corpus of text let's say Wikipedia using
this social supervision task and then
you can fine-tune it on a downstream
task and the incredible thing is that
these things just accrue information
they accrue knowledge about the world
you can ask it how old is Obama and it
will know the answer it's incredible the
current revolution in neural
representations for natural language
originated with Michael loves word Tyvek
the skip grand model in 2013 and it was
such a simple architecture it used a
contrast of loss which we spoke about
last week and it just asked the simple
question does this word belong in the
context of this other word just using a
fully connected architecture and a
negative sampling strategy with a
contrast of loss you could project these
words into an embedding space that
reflected their linguistic context ok
fine but the problem is the words were
atomic the words didn't really take into
account the structure and language has
this incredible structure words can
modify each other from a long distance
and those relationships can be multi
scale and and complex so the first
evolution along the road was we started
to have language models like Elmo
which started to use bi-directional LS
TMS to model the dependencies that
adjacent sequential dependencies between
tokens and this was starting to capture
some of the the meaning encoded in
language now you Alan Thicke came along
and this is when things really started
to get interesting because you will M
fit by Jeremy Howard and Sebastian ruder
this was the first model that
essentially did transfer learning so you
could build a language model that was
just predicting the next word using a
bi-directional well STM but then exactly
the same as what happens in computer
vision you can do transfer learning you
can just take off the last few layers
and then you can put a classifier on and
you can get it to do something
completely different so pre-trained a
language model on on wikipedia take the
last layer off turn it into a classifier
and do sentiment analysis you've got
that transfer of knowledge between the
self supervised pre training task and
that essentially means we've got more
training data and and the language model
already knows loads and loads of
concepts which will be useful for our
downstream tasks now in 2017 was an
interesting year this is when a chap
called Vaswani
came about from google he brought in a
paper called attention as all you need
and this introduced transformers and
transformers are an entirely new
architecture in your network design so
we have densely connected networks and
we have recurrent neural networks and we
have convolutional neural networks
transformers are an entirely new
paradigm an entirely new type of network
architecture oran ins and CNN's had been
the flavor of the day to build language
models they have some interesting
properties they could support variable
length sequences CN NS could easily be
parallelized
they had linear or logarithmic
interaction lengths between tokens the
main issue was that they only modeled
local dependencies between tokens in
CNN's long-term dependencies required
many layers and was lossy even gans now
are using self attention due to their
ability to model long range multi scale
complex dependencies allowing us to
capture more symmetries and patterns in
the data within the input size limit
tape
myth 6 in the seven myths of ml research
in early 2019 tried to dispel this idea
that transformers were more parameter
efficient discussing lightweight and
dynamic convolutions as an alternative
with similar results on machine
translation tasks transformers have
their own architectural challenges they
can only work within a bounded length
input size and they have nonlinear
interaction distance between tokens and
their memory intensive as hell see
people used to process the sequences of
text using recurrent neural networks but
that had a problem namely if you have a
long sentence such as J's shared beer
with his friend then to understand what
his friend means we need to know that
Dave was at the beginning of the
sentence a recurrent neural network
needs to store the fact that Dave was
there until it processes the end of the
sentence and that can be very difficult
to learn so a transformer can do this in
one step it can go from anywhere to
anywhere are using an attentional
mechanism
fast forward to November 2018 a chap
called Jacob Devlin released a paper
called Burt pre-training of deep
bi-directional transformers for language
understanding this was a game changer
not only because there's been a tsunami
of NLP papers recently which modify or
modulate certain aspects of this but but
even more so many of the the titles of
the paper pun on the word birds and I
think that's testament if nothing else
to the to the impact that this paper has
had but it was a by directional encoder
decoder transformer with 12 encoder
decoder layers and it had a pre-training
task which was doing a loss master
language model and next sentence
prediction and then it was also
fine-tuned on downstream tasks the
larger version of the model had about
340 million parameters which was quite
large at the time now because of the
bi-directional context it did
particularly well on certain tasks
downstream so it was state-of-the-art on
question answering since birth there's
been a tsunami
papers modulating some of the key
findings that were in Beart these papers
even mention Burt or pun on the name
Burt in the title so we had things like
Roberto and Albert and the still Burt
and Burt on stilts but the problem is
for the average consumer like ourselves
what we really want to do is is to
understand the relative contribution of
all of these different papers and being
able to categorize what their changes
our performance is introducing a new
self supervise appreciating objective
but also increasing the data set size
having a more in domain data composition
for increasing the size of the model
itself that's where this paper is so
important he's taking apart all these
different factors that can lead to
performance gains and isolating them in
this large-scale study of transfer
learning in the pre-training and
fine-tuning pipeline naturally image
processing so today we're talking about
exploring the limits of transfer
learning with a unified text to text
transformer by raffle and his colleagues
from Google this paper is basically a
huge Appalachian study it's just saying
what happens if we change all of these
different variables and and how do those
things affect the performance of these
language model across a suite of tasks
now one of the cool innovations in this
paper is that they created a text to
text architecture and what that means is
they didn't need to change anything even
though they were testing against many
different types of upstream tasks now
you might think that this is a form of
multitask learning and it kind of is but
it isn't they still fine-tune it on all
of the upstream tasks but they did do a
version where they trained it uniformly
across all of the tasks and after some
tweaking I was surprised to see that the
performance wasn't actually that bad and
what I mean by having a text to text is
in the input text you actually define
what the task is so you could say I want
you to translate this thing from English
to German and then you can say hello my
name is Tim and the language model will
pick up what tasks do you want to do and
it will give you the result as well and
incredibly there's no leakage between
the tasks it doesn't seem to degrade the
performance in any way by having this
text to text architecture remember to
Like comment and subscribe
and we will see you next week okay so
here we are welcome back to machine
learning Street Talk
today we are going to be talking about a
really really cool paper that came out
of Google and it is exploring the limits
of transfer in fact I'm just going to
share my screen so that's not okay okay
so welcome back to the machine learning
Street Talk YouTube channel I'm here
with my friends Yannick and Connor and
we're going to talk about a really
interesting paper today that came out of
Google I'm just going to share my screen
just to give you guys a bit of a flavour
so it's called exploring the limits of
transfer learning with the unified text
to text transformer and it has four
primary authors but it's Colleen raffle
at owl from Google and I think that the
main thing that raffle wanted to
demonstrate here was that since the Bert
paper in particular there's been an
onslaught there's just been a barrage of
different papers with different
variations changing the you know the
pre-training objective changing the
amount of time we train changing the
size of the data set and so on and I
think what what these guys have really
tried to do is to make sense of all of
that to kind of categorize the different
types of tweaks that all these papers
have introduced and to do a huge
ablation study to try and you know kind
of understand where most of the benefit
is coming from now if we scroll down to
the the takeaway section I think this is
quite interesting so that the first
thing is is this paper introduces a new
type of language model so called that
the t5 model and it's a text to text
model so I'll just read this bit out
here our text to text framework provides
a simple way to train a single model on
a wide variety of text tasks using the
same loss function and decoding
procedure we showed how this approach
can be successfully applied to
generative tasks like abstract
summarization classification tasks like
natural language inference an even
regression tasks like STS B in spite of
its simplicity we found that the text to
text framework obtained comparable
performance to task specific
architectures and ultimately produce
state-of-the-art results when combined
with with scale so what this means is
there are lots of different tasks in
language processing like translation and
question answering and normally you have
a different input architecture but now
they've homogenized that they have
a unified architecture so you can have
one model that does many many different
types of downstream tasks yeah but one
thing that I think is so interesting
about it is with respect to transfer
learning like when you're a developer
trying to take this model for your
application I think like it makes it so
much easier to figure out how to fit
your input-output into this kind of a
model for the sake of this pre-training
than fine-tuning pipeline so I'm curious
about like what you think about the
texted text input output for some
specific application compared to say
like you know bird or these other ways
where you would have to be more careful
about how not only how you're defining
your input output but also the
generality of this pre trained
representation is decreased by having to
be more specific with how you do input
output so for that reason I think the
transfer learning that's what I think is
the key benefit of the text to text
framework is that it makes transfer
learning easier yeah so I think this is
very much and they say that as well
depending on how you do the pre training
even in this text the text framework
right now maybe we should surely maybe
people haven't read the paper so in this
framework if you let's say want to do a
translation from English to French you
would not you would not train a model
for that specifically but you would
simply say translate to French or
translate from English to French :
and then you put the text of all of this
as text so the instruction itself is
also text and then they they define
various pre training tasks where
basically the model is supposed to fill
in parts of this text and I I think the
performance now really depends on how
you do this pre training and I think
that's that's a one part that they show
in the paper but I what I love about it
is the fact that everything is text now
and it is so cool
yeah I can also see it like in the
multimodal like the image bird like
trying to combine the images and yeah I
guess sort of having this representation
of text is super interesting to me
because it makes it so you don't have to
be so specific about how you define even
the pre-training I think like because
even just going from like Bert has this
mass language modeling objective that
fits nicely into like the sentiment
classification because you do that next
sentence prediction throughout the
pre-training but I think you don't have
to be as careful with the pre-training
in and how that fits into the downstream
task yeah though it's it's it I mean
it's always what they what they like we
don't we've gone through the takeaways
and one like two takeaways go like we
can do this and this and this and then
we combine it with scale and then it
becomes it becomes like state of the of
the art again so it is unclear to me how
much that scale influences this and how
much the the actual objective influences
this right there's a lot of uncertainty
with respect to all of these transformer
family for example this this next
sentence prediction task I think in the
in the bird paper that was specifically
mentioned as you know we try to
understand and so on but then in
subsequent papers people have some
people have claimed this is necessary we
just do mask language modeling don't
worry about this this pre-training this
this next so it to me it is still
somewhat unclear where the magic is in
these things I don't know how you see
that yeah yeah it seems like I mean I
definitely think like the Elektra
objective with the generator isn't is an
interesting way of doing this it seems
challenging to I mean I hadn't read span
bird before reading this paper and I
thought just that little modification
that they do seem to show provides more
benefits so it's definitely like I don't
know is there like a lot of opportunity
for exploration and the self supervisor
objectives I don't think it seems pretty
explored to me like
you know it definitely is an obvious
some way of doing further I mean they've
even tried the shuffling and Excel med
of scrambling sentence it seems like
they've pretty much tried at all to me
with the pre-training objective but yeah
it definitely was interesting to see all
these little things combined together
and like apples to apples compared in
this framework I don't think anything
else has done that at this level I mean
one thing that interests me because I
must admit every time I look at
transformers there's always a small part
of me that worries that I don't
completely grasp what's going on and for
example the vast one is original paper
on transformers was an encoder decoder
and then Burt apparently is an encoder
and the GPT variants and that you know
that the Nvidia what was the large and
video one Megatron Megatron that's a
good name and Mike Microsoft of course
have just brought out project cheering
which is about an eighteen billion
dollar at 18 billion parameter model and
those ones are you know cause or
autoregressive language model so those
are only decoders so can you guys put a
bit of detail on the difference between
them so yeah and in in a in an encoder
decoder framework you do what people
originally did with Ellis TMS right
where you have an input and you encode
it fully into like a Haydn
representation and then you decode from
that hidden representation now you can
have things like attention and so on
going there but basically you have two
separate modules one is at the end coder
and one is the decoder and with with for
example Bert Burgess as you said just
the encoder so you put in a sequence and
you get out and exactly same length
sequence so you with pure Bert you can't
do something like produce language
technically I mean people do it but
technically it's
it's kind of shaky how to do that but
what you can do is for example classify
each location do span prediction and so
on
but if you modify this bird architecture
such that your encoder you just make it
wider such that you can put the input
and part of the output as the input and
then you do this kind of masked
attention such that the one token in the
output can only ever look at its
predecessors right then all of a sudden
you now have a classification where you
can do language or sequence to sequence
tasks using this so I think the the the
big thing here is replacing this to
module thing with the funky masked
attention causally masked attention such
that you can do this
this decoding well asides from the
translation models like when do you
think it's interesting to encode only
the inputs and then to code like only
from the encoders representation like I
guess maybe like summarization you could
take the original document and then
encode it and then only decode from that
what the encoders produce but like jet
so like I guess the way I've been
thinking about decoder only is that it
it doesn't make any sense to be encoding
like having explicit encoders and
decoders with most of these tasks play
summarization I guess yeah one want us
to say even even the original
transformer in attention is all you need
was auto regressive in the sense that it
had attention on the thing that that the
decoder produced it was just that there
were two separate modules for that and
now there there isn't it's all basically
one set of parameters so I think the the
main benefit might come from just the
fact that there's parameter sharing
between all of these things generally
seems to help to just make your matrices
larger but share them across the
across the modules yeah what do you
think about parameter sharing it sounds
like such an odd thing to me that is it
like so I have like parameter it do they
both get gradient updates and then is it
like kind of like how when you have a
quantized codebook that you take all of
the updates that came from every
parameters that shares that weight or is
it just like copying it I mean parameter
sharing seems like it definitely seems
like a way to save especially the memory
with respect to storing the model
parameters but it seems like odd share
the encoder and decoder parameters I
don't quite get like the idea behind
that it's strange isn't it because it's
kind of similar to the way Siamese
networks work but you know rather than
happening in parallel what's happening
in series so why we're doing the same
thing many many times be beneficial and
why could you not shortcut I mean I
suppose a neural network is like a
computer program isn't it the idea is is
you are successively making
transformations that transform data from
one manifold to another manifold to
another manifold but why would you need
to do that the same way in many
intermediate steps right yeah it doesn't
make sense it's like the same exact
transformation applied again but I guess
I guess it's it's got a like yeah I
guess it's gotta have something to do
with if you just you know it's such a
complex series of transformations that
if you copy and then paste it eight
layers layer it'll be making a
significant difference I guess yeah
that's parameter sharing idea definitely
seems like just like an efficiency thing
I guess yeah I don't know I don't know
if I've read anything that is doing like
a big study on parameter sharing other
than like neural architecture search
well what I'm what I meant with the
original when I said parameter sharing
was more like if why why should I
why should I have 10 weights in my
encoder and 10 weights in my decoder
when I can have 20 weights in a module
that does both at the same time right it
seems that that seems to benefit more no
with respect to parameter sharing I
would say the way you can make the sense
of it is if you think of these layers
computing
maybe subroutines of a program and then
like common sub routines like
aggregating features in a certain way
sorting them or something like this and
if you think of it like this like you a
subroutine in a program you can call it
all over and it's kind of the same thing
but that is speculation yeah I like this
concept that you know there's over
parameterization in the models as well
because several of the the architectures
that have come out recently and in
particular I'm looking at distill Bert
and that has a kind of teacher and
student concept it's all about knowledge
distillation and the idea is is that you
train a normal-size model but then you
come up with a student model which is
40% smaller and 60% faster and inference
and you just get the student to clone
the teacher so you know you just train
them against each other and then the
student model retains about 97% of the
performance but it's a little bit like
the lottery ticket hypothesis when you
know we asked the question why do we
need to have all of this over
parameterization in the training phase
yeah so I think the the idea of this has
been in production in in many places I
think this is common in industry that
you train big models and then you kind
of just push them down because they want
to serve them out right these are you it
the idea of that is not super new but
it's it's pretty cool to see this it
applies to transformers because of
course they are very very large and
demanding and it is still a let's say a
mystery why any of this works right
because what what is what is surprising
is we get this small model that has such
a high performance but if we just train
the small model from start with the
training data we can never get that
performance we need to train the big
model with the same training data what
we need to train the big model and then
distill it to the small model in order
to get the small model to be so good so
it's
there is like as a weird interaction
there with where you have to argue the
Lord these large models something about
the over parameterization makes the
optimization procedure happy to accept
the training data into the model right
but then once you have it in the model
it seems like you can some sort of
transfer the features that it learned by
by distilling it like this it is it is
still I think this is still one of the
weirder aspects of all of this the fact
that this distillation works I think I
think you did just a plug for your video
and the lottery ticket hypothesis yeah
no you said it perfectly you said that
in a way it's quite depressing that this
is the way it works it's a bit like you
have a block of clay and you're kind of
chipping away at it with SGD and you
said because in most of these network
architectures they're so over
parameterised they actually contain n
choose P sub networks there's there's
this combinatorial explosion of
different sub networks and what at least
you know just probabilistically at least
one of those sub networks is likely to
provide a good inductive prior for the
problem but this is a horrible way to go
about it how does that pruning scale the
Transformers that involve taking out the
heads or is it like how to transport
house pruning scale to try like
transformers how do you find a lottery
ticket in the transformer
well one comment we can make is James
raffle in in this paper he tried over
parameterization as one of the tweaks
that we'll come to later so he increased
the model size and his comment was that
he just did it in the feed-forward
section he didn't touch the attention
it's that's really interesting yeah
because the transformer thing is and
it's not obvious how you would prune
that right because it's like an
operation on the set and it's like if
you can't just kill out the like
attention in an obvious way like you
could with it you know like a
feed-forward layer yeah I think I think
distillation is more of a testimony to
like the power of label smoothing and
label regularization like just even like
even if
you have the naive label smoothing wave
just like having say 90 percent
probability on the correct class and
then uniform probability everywhere else
I don't think distillation is really
like transferring the features from the
teacher model it's just like a more
clever way of doing this like label
regularization I guess like meta pseudo
labels is a recent paper that also shows
it like just a more clever way of
dynamically adjusting the labels in some
kind of way seems to be a really good
way to to train these neural networks
yeah that makes that makes sense though
is it is it known how this relation
works let's say across architectures
because what I can imagine is that by
doing this you know by outputting not
the labels but the probabilities of the
labels you implicitly transfer the
features because you your student has
the same architectural ID it's a
transformer and you're a transformer so
by outputting the exact probabilities
you're getting on each class that will
sort of implicitly transfer the features
because you know the same architecture
should learn the same features given the
same outputs right is it known how this
I don't know that is it known how
distillation works across architectures
like if I distill this maybe to an Alice
TM or something oh I know there's a
paper that does that that takes the
transformer labels and puts it in an LCM
but yeah I I mean the feature
transformation I think it's more so like
transferring its sense of like embedding
distances so it's almost like a metric
learning thing like is showing you like
hey this thing is like it's kind of like
a dog also but it's very far from a ship
whereas this other cat is closer to a
ship like I guess it's more of a like a
transfer of the distances between the
images in the data set and it is like
the features I guess but definitely like
super complex thing to try that is a
smart way could you could there maybe be
like a distillation procedure where you
use this notion of it's a distance
metric in with and do like some sort of
contrast of learning where you say these
two things should be closer together
than this other thing it seems
like something like this some
combination like this should be possible
yeah it sounds really it kind of reminds
me of like how they use kind of like how
neural style transfer uses the
intermediate features or like yeah
definitely a tricky thing but it
definitely seems interesting like that
idea of distillation with distance I
guess and thinking of it like that okay
well let's let's carry on reading a
little bit of the paper then so the
second part we started to talk a little
bit about the the encoder decoder
architecture and I didn't completely
understand that but let's read this
section so there's a real contribution
around architectures and it says well
some of our while some work on transfer
learning for natural language processing
has considered architectural variants of
the transformer we found the original
encoder decoder form worked best in our
text to text framework although an
encoder decoder model uses twice as many
parameters as an encoder only for
example Bert or a decoder only language
model so for example GPT it has a
similar computational cost we also
showed that sharing the parameters in
the encoder and the decoder did not
result in a substantial performance drop
while of course hovering the total
parameter count is that so just to
confirm the original Vaswani model was
an encoder decoder model or is it
referring to as Jannik was saying
earlier the original recurrent neural
network C to C type models I think the
original model was an encoder decoder I
just kind of made the connection so
because because their original sector
SEC frameworks also always talked of
encoders and decoders yeah I think it's
because and it makes intuitive sense
because the RN ends were learning a kind
of sequential representation and quite
clearly there was an encoder phase where
it was you know going from a sequence
into this flat internal representation
and then a decoder phase but
transformers are a little bit different
aren't they they don't they don't
flatten it into a representation and in
the same way the data still seems to
remain in the original time domain
yeah it's it um though though you cannot
wash out you get to wash out the
differences once you introduce attention
in two hours TMS and things like this I
I think it's it's mainly about it's
mainly about how you would you know
program the things here then then actual
ideological or mathematical differences
but yeah well what do you what do you
think about like the position embeddings
like that was when I first read the
attention is all you need paper it was
such a bizarre looking way of doing the
positional embeddings and I think now
they're doing these relative embeddings
it's like the transformer Excel so yeah
I guess yeah that's how they give them
time but it's very weird way I think you
you just know that you know they tried
it without and it just failed hard and
then they were like ah crap
you know because a transformer by itself
it has no notion of positions in the
sequence right it doesn't know where the
information is coming from it just knows
but it you can just query a kind of
information it can just address content
like by its content it cannot it cannot
ask where it's from and I guess they
just realized oh maybe the information
that something is you know at the
beginning at the end or you know - away
from this other thing is I mean it just
seems like it just seems weird to put it
even in but that's how you know you need
it right because the original paper
wouldn't have put it in if you hadn't
needed it but I find the way of doing
the position on coding using these sine
waves and quite a smart right because
what you're doing is you kind of
overlaying sine waves and then you one
is very slow and then the next one is
like faster and by indexing a point in
there you can kind of measure distance
to each of the in each of the scales so
the the large sine wave gives you a
large scale distance where and it's it's
sort of an encoding of your position
where you have you don't the model
doesn't need to do arithmetic s--
the model can just think what is my
close neighborhood and it goes to the
fastest sine wave and it can think what
it what things are around me in a large
sense and it goes to the slow sine wave
yeah so so I guess the way I think about
it is it's it's giving the model a ruler
because as Conor was saying the
transform is Excel that introduced
recurrence into the model and and then
of course you need to have a relative
positioning coding you know for all of
the the chunks but just coming back to
transformers for a sec I mean in
contrast to a recurrent neural network
where you're learning the sequential
representation so that it has some
concept of time built in but I suppose
it's actually more similar to the wave
reinforcement learning algorithms work
it's kind of everything about the past
is compressed into now but transformers
have this wonderful capability to model
I mean essentially you can attend from
any token to any other token so you can
learn these long term representations
but does it then use those positional
and codings as a kind of ruler to
measure how far away those things are
yeah I would I would guess that it is in
like that 95% of why these things help
is much more simple in explanation it's
just like oh this thing is at the start
right this is just like a hard attention
to the start of the sentence if the
start of the sentence says what or who
then that is an extreme and extreme bias
to understanding what the sentence means
right so I think a lot of the a lot of
the what these positional encodings give
you is very simple but then yes I think
some of it has to do with which words
are my neighbors which words are far
away which words are after me or before
me because that is very important right
yeah because one thing this brings to my
mind is I'm I'm really interested in the
concept of symmetries and of course the
CN n could could capture a translational
symmetry but could a transformer
captured
same symmetry because I don't like the
notion that this position of embedding
my hard-code the pattern such that this
particular pattern of text had to start
at the beginning of the sentence or at
the beginning of the input wouldn't it
be good if it had if it could learn the
pattern in some sort of sense that it
was let's say translationally invariant
or or even invariant to different scales
so it might be a pattern that happens at
different scales of language well in
some sense it already can if it just
pays attention to the correct magnitude
of the sine wave right if you if you
think of learning a phrase like My
Little Pony and you you take the exact
let's so on one on one point on the side
it is like here on the sine wave and
then here and then here and then the
other part of the sentence again it is
you know if because the sine wave
repeats I don't have good words for it
but maybe you realize that you have the
same pattern of the sine wave in both
locations and thereby you can learn if
after me if after the word my two words
after follows Pony then I you know then
I assigned this meaning and on the
higher level if you go up the sine wave
magnitudes you can learn something like
if there is a relative clause after a
person name then I assign the following
meaning right so you can learn these big
patterns on larger scales up in the
layers I think this this encoding of the
overlapping waves is very cool exactly
for that it is beautiful when you know
just to riff on that for a minute
intellectually I don't know whether that
they did an ablation study where they
took away the positional encodings but
if you think about it the model has no
concept of the relationships between the
tokens so it can only be using the
positional encoding and it raises all
sorts of interesting things in my mind
because does that mean that it's only
looking at the relative distance between
the tokens it's not actually looking at
the the context of the immediate words
surrounding that
tokens that it's attending to well who
knows I guess if you introduce these
relative encodings you have a very
direct access yeah to the immediate what
is your immediate context but even in
the indy like all things so first of all
I want to say the appellation I almost
guarantee you it does not work without
the position on codings because like
that's why they're there right from the
beginning I think they actually in t5
they use like a learner bol scalar
encoding so they get away for I think
they get away from the sign encoding
okay that's cool like yeah but okay yes
I guess the sign though I just don't get
it because it's like it seems to like
say you it would say like word eat is
more similar than word 15 you know what
I mean like it's sort of like
arbitrarily putting words but you know
in a way right in a way yes how I how I
see it is I so in my in my bachelor's
there used to be a group that did face
3d modeling and they had a machine where
they would 3d scan your face and how it
worked was quite cool in that it
projected patterns onto your skin first
there was just black here and white here
and then there was black white black
white and then there was black white
black white black white black white so
at the end every little pixel of your
face had its unique encoding of black
and white across these different scales
right it's like a like a binary pattern
through time and each pixel was unique
in that but it's not like neighboring
it's not like neighboring pixels would
always share the the biggest part of
their so I think of it like this you
could capture the two cheeks right
because they are equal in their bit
encodings except for the very first one
is black here and white here but other
than that there is a symmetry in the
higher layers I I think that it you
right of course it doesn't in a way it
will say these two words are more
similar than these
two words but you know if you if you do
this across the layers where the lower
layer could say my neighbors are
important and then the larger layers
could say you know my very far away's
are important that might do the trick
cool okay well let's read a little bit
more of the the take homes in the
message so the next one is talking about
unsupervised objectives now of course in
these self supervised language models
the the general modus operandi is that
there's this pre training task which
might do next sentence prediction or a
mask language model or or even something
else and and then of course you do the
fine-tuning later so it says overall we
found that most denoising objectives
which train the model to reconstruct
randomly constructed text performed
similarly in the text to text setup as a
result we suggest using objectives that
produced short target sequences so that
unsupervised pre training is more
computationally efficient yeah I thought
that was really cool too to not
reconstruct the entire tart like instead
of an like just reconstructing the mass
tokens as a part of the whole original
thing you only do what's been masked out
and I I think that like that definitely
probably speeds up the training enormous
ly by having this yeah like an like just
saying for inviting last I bet that that
like doubles the speed of doing this
yeah as so and they're saying it's
because the output spaces is smaller it
just makes it more efficient to Train I
find it fascinating by the way that that
would even work so you give it an input
of thank you me to your party week and
the target is for inviting lost and
somehow it manages to do that I mean
that blows my mind
yeah media especially because there's so
many different ways to fill that out
yeah I can't believe that one works yeah
it's fascinating just to look at the
evolution here of the different pre
training objectives on the self
supervised tasks and of course in the
Bert style model it was doing something
like this so you had a random number of
tokens and then the target was the
original text so of course that's quite
a large output space and then there's
the shuffling the words was was I don't
think that got particularly good results
and then there's this concept of masking
the tokens is is this the same as Bert
what's the difference between that and
Bert
I think the key difference is the span
and so so I think in Bert they also they
had two objectives there's they also
swapped some of the input tokens
randomly so that's why there's the Apple
in there and so but two year party Apple
week Andy and the bird model was asked
to also correct for that basically well
as here in the just mask tokens it's not
I think this one is the mass there's a
paper called mass and that was the the
objective in that paper hmm do you think
like you're switching out last for Apple
is useful I guess it looks like no well
as they say right most of these tasks
that the people come up with tend to do
equally well but it seems like it is
important that you do something like
this right because because if you just
try you like just take a Bert model and
just train it on question-answering
or sentiment class it may be sentiment
works everything works on sentiment but
if like on question answering it just
doesn't work so even though they say
most of these things perform similarly
it still seems to be important that you
do them and that you do this kind of
thing right but I yeah I was also pretty
impressed by the just the tasks that
came up with and yeah I think that's
cool yeah I think it even looks like a
pretty big game to go from 83 to 84
point 4 on the unlike all these glue
tasks also sorry I don't know if it
necessarily the conclusion of they're
all similar is right
boy I mean pretty similar but still
seems like a decent boost in the yeah
yeah but yeah also we've been thinking
about like the Electra pre training
objective where they have the generator
in a different way and wondering like if
they had put that into the pipeline like
what do you predict that that that would
be as good or or would it you know
probably be also this performs the same
as the others
well here you have to refresh me on the
Electra obvious the the adversarial
version
go ahead Cara oh yeah it's just like so
you you have your generator that is the
one that's going to corrupt the text so
it's like it's like a discriminator
objective rather than predicting the
mass token so you have like a low
parameter generator model that's filling
out the mass tokens but then the larger
scale model is just seeing like what
this like lower parameter generator
thought it should fill in the tokens
with so it's like a discriminator
objective rather than like reproducing
the sequence so it's giving you like 1-0
predictions of real or fake this is kind
of like the Gann framework yeah but I
don't know what to think of that it
sound it sounds like so I I just I know
that again like scans or something like
Gans for text or are still pretty far
away something like this it might work
it just seems like a Gann objective is
is a much much information lower
information task than the actual
language producing thing right but you
have to weigh that against the fact that
you know for any given gap in a sentence
you could fill in like 20 different
words and they would all perfectly make
sense right and here you are with your
training corpus telling your transformer
no this one this one is the one that I
want right and that
that's where where something like a
discriminator that just assigns a high
probability to all those 20 words can
come in and can really benefit you so I
have I have no guesses on ultimately
whether that's going to be good or bad
and I do not believe mostly do not
believe any numbers in any papers
because ultimately what happens is they
they just they come up with their new
idea and they just throw more more
resources at it or a bigger corpus or
it's a little different trick here or it
is just so hard to compare these things
even if they go through the extreme like
pains of of doing all these ablations it
it just seems weird what do you think
about like the difference between when
they have competitions to evaluate the
paper so it's like do you think maybe
that does a better job of like
decoupling these sort of easy things to
add on to it because if you have like a
KAG of competition it's like everyone is
gonna be you know augmenting the data
like crazy ensemble in the models and
given it as much computers they got I
think maybe competitions are a better
way to tease apart algorithms like but I
guess like the benchmarks don't seem to
do that you know yeah this is one of the
key things that Sholay is talking about
in his you know measuring intelligence
paper you know he says that we've
centered around that this notion that
benchmarking and competitions is the
best way to get to get that the best
result and CAG or sometimes can produce
perverse results because we become so
fixated on the benchmark that the
winning solution doesn't even generalize
to the real-world version of the problem
yeah definitely I mean there are let's
say there are there are two two
arguments here or two two modes one is
benchmark or competition is the way we
evaluate things right and the other one
is someone you know reads all the papers
implements them carefully does the same
hyper parameters in the same amount of
CPU cycles for for all the models and
then reports the numbers and both are
just crap respectively right
if you go for the I actually I'm on the
side of the competition because if you
say just whatever the highest number you
get you know whatever you have to do for
it
do it right and and and you're maybe not
cannot interpret where exactly your
gains come from but at least you get
like an absolute number this is how far
you can push this right with with
everything you've got
whereas if someone goes and just
implements all the things we've seen
this there's this kind of famous paper
that said all gangs are created equal
right and they implemented all these
gains and then the authors of the
Vossler Stan Gann they came along and
said clearly we stated in our paper that
our algorithm only works with ID only
remember rmsprop or not with Adam or
something like this and then in this
paper they had our hyper parameter grid
is these algorithms right and they said
in their paper it doesn't work like that
right and then and then so so it seems
to me that all options are bad but if
push comes to shove I am more on the
side of the competitions but I think
ultimately you as a practitioner the
best thing you can do is look at all of
these different papers and just kind of
try to crystallize out not really
believe anyone individually but
crystallize out if you see tricks over
and over again if you see architecture
types over and over again that's
probably what's going to work it does
make me think of some of the comments
that Shirley was talking about though in
in his paper I mean he used the example
that in the 1980s you people like Marvin
Minsky had quite narrow definitions of
AI in it and it seemed to center around
how well you can perform a task but it's
a different metric for humans and
algorithms because if an algorithm can
beat the world chess player that doesn't
seem particularly impressive but if a
human can that's very impressive and
that's because that the human is is
learning how to become that highly
skilled and I think increasingly when we
look at it reminds me of when we talked
about the the
uber trailblazer because that was all
about a system that learns and produces
its own curriculum and I think that
these competitions and these benchmarks
they're so narrow minded that they stop
us from making progress in what
artificial intelligence should be which
is being able to learn things
dynamically well is there is the
question even to make progress in
artificial intelligence because it like
you know for for I don't know a company
like Google it's just if their
translation model is better than
everyone else's then they get money
right that's that's but but the other
thing is with regards to intelligence I
think if you give a human the same a
notion the same amount of time in actual
raw let's say compute time when you like
neuron firings versus GPU cycles and if
you give it the same amount of memory
where it can write down all the things I
would not be surprised it becomes much
better at chess I think the impression
of the humans like they're so good
because also there's limited time and we
kind of get a feeling of how how just
hard it is to do that but yeah I'm have
a feeling we'll be doing a measure of
intelligence talk very soon I think like
what do you think about like the dawn
bench like the idea of like limiting the
computation of resources for a task and
for a competition because it seems to me
like you can't really have this thing
where you have like fair computation for
everyone and then still do something
interesting with the models and are like
interesting on the scale as if it was
unbounded so definitely I definitely
think like the it seems to me like the
best effort for like machine translation
and all that wouldn't even be to play
with the algorithm looked a bitter
lesson to just figure out how we can
train a hundred billion parameter
transformers or a trillion parameter and
it's like like whatever is the
difference between like the TPU and the
GPU and how that enables these like
larger scale matrix multiplies it seems
like the chip engineering is a more
promising direction for this kind
thing yeah and the data the data collect
I had some interesting conversations
with friend once and I was basically
arguing the point that you know you
should get equal resources and things
like this and his point was very clear
that and I found it very good that there
are effects that only come out at scale
right there are there are effects that
these models capture that can they can
only capture because they have a billion
parameters and because they have 50
terabytes of training data and it is
true the only objective real number that
you have is if you have unbounded
computation if you have unbounded
everything how well can you perform now
it's an entirely different task to say
you get this many CPU cycles because if
I want to engineer something in a mobile
phone I care about that right but it's
it's a narrower field let's say but
that's and that's quite a nice segue to
talk about the the data sets section of
the paper because some of the papers in
this area like Roberta for example and
they discovered that birth just simply
wasn't trained for long enough it was it
was under trained and as I think if
we'll find out in this T 5 paper and
training more is one of the most
effectual strategies but just to read
this data sex datasets section in the
take homes we introduced the colossal
Colleen crawled corpus c4 they released
this by the way which comprises
heuristic ly clean text from the common
crawl web dump when comparing see for
two datasets that use additional
filtering we found that training in
domain unlabeled data could boost
performance in a few downstream tasks
however constraining to a single domain
typically results in a smaller data set
we separately showed that the
performance can degrade when an
unlabeled data set is small enough that
is repeated many times over the course
of three training and this motivates the
the use of a large and diverse data set
like c4 for generic language
understanding tasks so they had they
started off with this c4 which is this
huge data set it's 745 gigabytes
I suppose what surprised me is no sorry
that that's filtered it was 6.1
terabytes and after they filtered it it
got down to 745 gigabytes and by
filtering it they removed all of the
JavaScript I think they only took
sentences that ended in a period they
did it you know I think they did some DG
plication but and it's surprising how
much they could they could filter away
yeah I actually thought another thing
that was kind of interesting is like
even though it the current pipeline is
like there's tons of unlabeled text
available and then it's like it almost
seems like natural language processing
is the thing to benefit from this
I don't supervise pre-training than
fine-tuning but I but it seems to me
like so they're able to get 750
gigabytes of text from the entire
Internet and then they have like 20
gigabytes of Wikipedia plus the books
with another interesting thing in the
paper that you're going through if you
go to table 12 in the paper yeah on my
way yes like it's like look that the
supervised multitask pre training is
already it's only like three points
behind unglue so it's like what will
scale like probably the supervised like
people are coming out with supervised
natural language processing datasets
like every day so it's like I would
actually predict that the supervised
multitask pre training is going to be
the more scalable thing in the future
because you can't get that much
unsupervised I mean you can you get a
lot now but in the people just build out
and label these data sets it might be
that the paradigm shifts and images is
the thing that we think of this
unsupervised pre training pipeline as
because you can go drive a self-driving
car around and get like more images and
you could even store in a data set but
it seems like maybe the supervised task
is what will scale with language that's
interesting because I think the
take-home from this paper was that it is
still better to do unsupervised pre
training but it does seem to indicate
that the magic of unsupervised training
is is simply that you get more data so
you you were training for longer with
more data and that allows you to to
learn better but that they did some
interesting experiments didn't they with
this so they tried not even doing the
the unsupervised preacher
at all and then they did something
similar to Microsoft's MTD NN which is
when you and do multitask learning so
and you need to you do a uniform task
learning over all of the tasks and then
you use separately fine tune for all of
the downstream tasks and that seems to
significantly improve the performance
yeah I definitely think that multistage
like do your unsupervised math language
modeling and then even just even if you
just do the same self supervised task
but like on in domain data I think
that's another huge characteristic of
this is like this gain you get when
you're doing the ablation of the data
sets and if you're like if you're doing
your pre training on the Wikipedia data
you'll do better on like squad and
you'll do worse on like Cola because
it's never seen an unacceptable sentence
before in Wikipedia so it has no sense
of that yeah maybe maybe that's I mean
the large part of the effect is just
gonna come from the fact that you have
never seen text like you're gonna get in
these tasks right whereas with with the
images it is gonna be the same images
that or it is going to be natural images
all the way through it's not like the
it's not like a visual question
answering tasks all of a sudden has like
a big arrow on the image like this thing
what is this thing called right and and
you've never seen that during training
right so I think that that is real the
distinction here the fact that they now
frame everything in text and there are
structures and there is unacceptable
sentences and so on that the model has
never ever seen during training it can't
make it can't make sense out of it so
these on task free training might be
exactly doing this like providing the
model with a sense of the type of data
that it's going to get during the during
the the actuals fine-tuning stage and
that I mean they kind of shoot
themselves in the foot a bit here by
saying that because
puts into question how much you can gain
by all this huge pre-training right if
ultimately our explanation is going to
be well you still need to see the kind
of data that your task is on and if you
do then you're not that much worse yeah
how interested are you in in like meta
learning where the definition of it is
like domain appetit add app tation or
like rapid changing to a new like kind
of environment like i like things like
kind of like mammal where they try to
find like a good set of initial
parameters such that when you do domain
shift it's like quickly adapts to this
you know going from like wikipedia to i
don't know one of the like the books
corpus or something like what do you
think about meta learning in domain data
do you think like it's possible to
really have like an unsupervised
representation that can work for every
domain or do you think you necessarily
need to have this other mechanism that
does domain adaptation I think one way
of describing is there are more
similarities between language corpora
then there are dissimilarities so I
suppose by doing that unsupervised
training you are capturing as much
useful generalizable information as
possible but as you say there are many
words which mean different things in
different domains so in the financial
world the word default is a very very
bad word I I in with regards to metal
learning I always find these meta
learning papers it's a bit because we
just don't have that many tasks even in
NLP and even though people are coming
out with new data sets all the time it
just seems there's this limited amount
of tasks and the kind of limited ways in
which things are diverse and then to
truly claim you have now have an
initialization that works on general
language it seems a bit of an over claim
of all of these papers i i've seen the
same thing with this there was this
visual task adaptation benchmark by by
google where the same thing read you
want to pre train on something like
imagenet but then you only have a
thousand samples for all of these other
tasks it just seems these tasks are all
too similar such that it's you can't
really then make this
that you found something general so I'm
a bit skeptical in that way but it's it
I think it's a very cool cool field and
if possible then I think that especially
for practitioners that will be
game-changing if the if like you can do
something like this I have to say with
respect to the data set it's called
colossal and I think the community might
be running out of words that describe
large things
there's Megatron and then there's a XL
net right and the transformer X and it's
what you know so I I wonder how high
they can push this world game and also
they release this which means that
someone at open air I must must have
been having a heart attack because how
can you release something that's so
dangerous like this is like ten times as
dangerous as the open AI corpus would
have been exactly I mean one one
comments I did want to make is it's
actually not that big so their data set
which they call real news like I think
that's or webtext like I think that's
their equivalent of what they did with
GPT too so they filtered this this
corpus on to high quality news articles
and I think that meant things that were
linked from reddit that had been up
voted at least three times and this is
only about thirty five gigabytes but the
close score is significantly higher than
the than the filtered see for ya ever
say how the heck is that it's only
twenty times larger all the internet
texts compared to like that isn't that
interesting I think it's like also like
kind of this is kind of like we're like
the privacy thing gets funny it's like
if you were to like go through like
everybody's Facebook messages or like
their Twitter direct messages and
conversations like that I feel like you
could get so much more like good text
data if you were to like you can't you
know break
kind of like privacy thing and how
enticing well I think especially so it
is especially these things are
especially wearing because it seems like
these transformers are getting so large
that in essence they're just kind of
remembering the training data and
interpolating between the training data
because so I've always get the
impression that to really make the next
step in something like NLP you need a
grounding of this knowledge I always
think of this surely as example with the
ORAC challenge where you you have a
picture and these pixels are black and
then there are like three blue pixels
and two orange pixels going away and
it's clearly like something is bouncing
off a wall but we can understand it
because we live in the physical world
where things bounce off things right I
think the next step needs to happen in
terms of grounding and these models
don't have it and so all they can really
do and all they do is they interpolate
patterns that they see in the training
data and these models are getting so
large that they almost they I'm pretty
sure they just remember the entire
training corpus and they kind of figure
out how to mix and match right so they
they were like oh here's a noun and then
the sentence kind of starts with these
words so I'm gonna finish it with this
example from the training data right or
with these mix of these two I'm pretty
sure they don't learn very sophisticated
things they just learn how to mix and
match training their their mind there
was a the privacy czar it come comes in
through that so even worse right there
is this xkcd comic where they start
writing the email with the the next
meeting of the rebellion leaders yeah so
my question on the idea of like language
grounding is like what do you ground it
in so you could have like these
text-based adventure games where you you
you know you get this text prompt that's
like you're in a dungeon you see this
thing on the table what
you want to do and you navigate the
world with text in that way chatbox are
kind of like rounded in that similar way
where you have a reaction from what
you're saying and then there's things
like point scale navigation or the Allen
Institute's bro both or thing where
you're like navigating a visual world
based on like language cues there's also
something called read to fight monsters
which is where you get to like
description of the game you're about to
play in language and then you go and
play the game so it's like in order to
ground the language you have to have the
context around it I guess and it's I
guess it's unclear how you would define
that well I these these these text
adventure games and all of these things
are it's a nice idea but if you want to
make this machine learning capable you
need a lot of it right so you need a lot
of text adventures and you're only gonna
get that by someone writing a procedural
generator of the text and that means
you're not dealing with language you're
dealing with a procedurally generated
grammar where you basically just always
kind of look for the same patterns of
words that the the simulator writer put
in it's it's what I mean by grounding is
more like if you if I say there is a car
around the corner I live in the physical
world I know cars or objects there on
roads a coroner means a house coroner in
this particular case right so there is
like a road and there's a road here and
there's a house in between and I can't
see the car but it's around the corner I
love Shirley's concept though that in
intelligence is very much linked to the
world in the environment that we live in
and that that's his major argument why
there can be no explosion of
intelligence but I really like some of
the stuff you were saying before as well
about you know neural networks are
basically just memorizing machines and
you could argue that we are the same I
mean philosophically speaking if we if
we could remember everything and this
conversation now is just us
regurgitating things that we've picked
up from random places and we're not
really thinking fluidly and
intelligently of course that's not true
I mean what Chalet would say is that we
have this problem in deep learning that
there's minimal generalization so in
order to learn anything we have to do
memorization and there is this wonderful
paper a few years ago that said that
deep learning algorithms don't
extrapolate they just interpolate and
the the argument that it gave was you
know let's try and learn the scale our
identity function which is basically f
of x equals x so it's the simplest
function in the whole world to learn I
mean I know but this is really neural
network I think they they trained it
between -5 and 5 and then they they
tested it in inference outside of the
training range with a whole bunch of
different activation functions and you
know what none of them could extrapolate
isn't that tragic
yeah but how important yeah I guess but
it's such a hard concept to define it
like back to this idea of like language
grounding and this idea of go look at
the car that's around the corner is
Google just released this like like
Street view images data set where you're
going through the street view and you're
navigating based on language like with
enough data you know you can interpolate
between vision and language probably you
probably can navigate very well with
language so then yes so I guess it's
like extrapolating is it is it necessary
and can we even define it
because what because then you're like
okay I can do vision and language but
it's still not intelligence like what
else do you want to add to it like audio
true right it's it's at some point
because embodied cognition which is
basically what I'm talking about right
that you live in the world it we only
live in the world via our senses right
so there is our senses and then our
brain that has been optimized to make
right to in but it's it's all it's just
input signals right that we interact
with the world and one can argue that if
you give a neural network and off of
these different modalities it might be
able to make the same connections that
that is true yes absolutely
and in a super way because like Tim said
he can recall everything you've ever
experienced ok instantly yes yeah yeah
that would be a curse that wouldn't be a
good thing
I saw I can no sorry going the the
notion of notion of this generalization
I also don't I also don't know how so if
you if you think of this identity
function like who's to stew who's to say
that we don't want the network to learn
a function that goes like this and then
back to the mean right it's only because
you tell the human or the human kind of
does this is this extrapolation but
based on what that's my question like do
we have the intrinsic notion that the
pattern must go on with the identity
function and how are we doing this I
think that's the big question to answer
yeah it's interesting because as you say
in in the real world we have some kind
of useful inductive prior which allows
us to reason about how things in the
world relate to each other but in
mathematics if it's just a such a simple
function why why would it be so
difficult to extrapolate that well I
think I guess like also one thing is
like sort of like why I got really
interested in generative adversarial and
that works is I think like studying the
way like a generator that produces like
high dimensional output rather than
classification labels is such a more
interesting way to look at
generalization because you can give it
like this data set of cats and you get
to be like did you design a new cat
according to like my sense of I think
it's yeah I just think it's another more
interesting like thinking about
generalization is models that are like
creating things that are not just
labeling them that's quite interesting
though because is that generalization or
not yeah needs like like disentangled
representations is another thing I
really want to get into is like is like
when you can learn how to like take the
hat just take the hat off the guy just
put sunglasses on them you know like
take apart the factors that's super
interesting oh yeah so you can do I'm
gonna continue going down the paper yes
you're sure we keep digressing but it's
it's no bad thing I think
that's what this whole channel is about
it's it's called machine learning Street
talk for a reason now they talk about
training strategies and I think here
what they're talking about is I mean
what struck me is if it truly was a
multitask model that would be wonderful
because they got best results by fine
tuning in the end on the respective
tasks but imagine if you did just have
this language model which was multitask
that this is almost like something you
get in Star Trek you say to the model I
want you to translate something from
English to German and it's Hello
something or other and the model will
without any leakage between the tasks
just give you the result they got pretty
good results on that I mean that just
blows my mind though again they're there
you have to to say that it is it isn't
really the model is probably not really
learning the meaning of the sentence I
want you to translate this is probably
they're just prepend that that exact
sentence to all the translation tasks
right and then fine tune it and the
model just needs to learn that that
particular combination of tokens is now
indicating the language it's it's not
it's not understanding the I want you to
do something oh no no absolutely but I
suppose what it is doing is it this huge
a model is a computer program it's it's
it's kind of partitioning the model it's
delegating responsibility so yes some
parts of the model is responsible now
for doing translation but what's
interesting is the interconnected and
shared nature it's not it's not like
it's saying oh well the you know the top
part of the model is going to do the
translation it's actually reusing
representations I mean it's interesting
to talk about the DMT DNN paper from
Microsoft because that does multitask
learning as part of the pre-training
before we fine-tune and the the the the
take-home message seemed to be that by
training on multiple tasks at the same
time it gives you a kind of
regularization because you're learning
representations that are useful and have
utility across all of the tasks
yes that's very very believable I think
it's it would be extremely interesting
if we had better introspection into
these text models to see what's what's
really going on like how how far up are
these things shared or is it is it just
the case that maybe just the word
embeddings are shared and then the model
just divides itself and we're just like
okay you two attention heads if whenever
there's translation you do that right
and you all you others do the the other
thing right and then maybe as tasks are
similar it would be very interesting to
to perform like introspective analyses
on exactly these models how much the
representations are shared where the
subroutines are reused across and maybe
you find some some super interesting
things so there it was this paper a
while ago that did zero shot translation
I don't know if you've seen something
like this where what you do what I think
what you do first is you pre train on
let's say English and then you just
fine-tune the word embeddings of French
and then you can like input English and
output friend I don't exactly remember
how it went but you can do like zero
shot translation without ever having
trained on that particular language pair
so is that is that that because some of
the recent neuro translation models
essentially what they do is they
translate if it's trained in a
multilingual way they will translate all
of these different languages into a
common intermediate representation so in
that sense it could translate between
almost anything it's not it wasn't the
same thing but I'm gonna find it here
because it was pretty interesting and it
basically showed that there is something
going on like an abstractive language
understanding I'm not saying rounding or
intelligence but just like an
abstractive notion of of language where
maybe okay English in French okay
together but you know there's something
going on that's beyond just a single
task and it would be again it would be
super interesting to see how these
multiple tasks and objectives are
handled in the representations
throughout the layers of the transformer
I wonder whether someone's done a paper
on that because when you started to put
your hypothesis on the table about the
it being partitioned rather neatly with
the attention heads that was quite
convincing to me so maybe it does do
that because if it is just if it were a
horrible fully connected neural network
then of course it would be very very
difficult to understand what's going on
but for some reason having clean
partitioning across the attention heads
that seems like it would be more likely
to happen yeah it kind of is like a
conditional computation model to with
how it routes it to the attention heads
a little bit oh not really yeah but like
so it's multitask learning and I
actually hadn't understood that I
thought it actually was understanding
that like summarize so that I'd like
understood that and then summarized it
so I didn't I I thought that it did have
a sense of that like if you I thought
that one of the cool things about the
text of text tasks is that maybe if you
had this new task like like who is the
pronoun referring to you could like
prefix it with that and then the
sentence and it would learn it a little
faster than if you had say embedded like
zero zero zero one zero zero indicates
like pronoun disambiguation or something
like that yeah yeah I mean it goes to
show as well that I love this concept
that neural networks are basically
computer programs albeit ones that are
differentiable because as you say there
is actually no difference just to using
a piece of text it it's still just
processing it in exactly the same way
with almost no leakage but do you think
it picks up the new tasks faster so this
is the this is like to me what's so
interesting about text the text being
something that can enable transfer
learning do you think it picks up the
new task but let's say you come up with
some I don't know like some prefix tasks
in natural language and then you give it
the task after the coal
do you think it will maybe learn that
faster than as if it was like totally
zero shot and then like there's some say
embedding vector or norm extra like
normalization parameters that tell it
that this is this new task well I
suppose it would be hard to give it an a
one hot vector because it because
actually the the the tokens are encoded
using some word vectors so it's in a
much higher dimensional space but
assuming that you you replicated
something similar I don't see why it
would make any difference
you could you could just put some
garbage there but just always the same
garbage right but something that does
not in natural language mean the task
that it that you mean it to mean you get
like so instead of saying translate from
English to French you just say I don't
know
sandwiches are nice but always he always
always whenever there is translate from
English to French you always say
sandwiches are nice right and then this
that would be maybe a cool experiment to
see whether it actually helps that it
has probably seen the phrase translate
in that context somewhere in the in the
training data and you know there might
be a bias towards there now being
multiple languages I don't know but it's
a cool experiment school idea yeah like
maybe the training curve is a little bit
faster because it is still taking that
summarize and then hitting the go and
embeddings table with it and getting a
sense of what it means hopefully like
the embedding has a sense of summarized
yeah oh yeah that that's less exciting
to me yeah unfortunately the it's never
as exciting as it sounds at first sight
I mean just to kind of talk about the
the lost you know think that they've
really played within in the paper and
it's almost depressing that it's the
scale and the amount of training that
made the largest you know the difference
to the results so the baseline on glue
and by the way that there's another
thing called super glue in it and we can
pull up the paper for that but that's a
more surface
dedicated version of blue like
challenges because we were getting too
good at the glue benchmark but yeah the
baseline was eighty three point two
eight and when they did four times as
many training steps it went up to about
eighty five point three three so that's
about two points up and the biggest
improve from it was was when they
increased the size of their network at
you know number of parameters by by two
and they did that not by changing
anything in the attention heads but by
increasing the number of parameters and
the feed-forward layers and they also
did two times as many training steps and
that gave them essentially three points
of improvement which is huge yeah I
think what what will happen is that like
this we were talking earlier about you
only get 750 gigabytes of like taking
all of the text from the internet and
then you know with the more clean
datasets you get like 20 or 30 so I
think what will happen is that you'll
train this really large model and then
it'll just do like one pass through it
other like you know it won't like I
think the size is gonna scale better
than training steps because it seems to
me like they'll figure out how to train
like a hundred trillion transformer
before they'll figure out how to get
like the corresponding data set size
because like the two have to go together
with that scaling I guess it's quite
interesting as well because there there
are some weird things that happen when
you increase that the training size when
they did the multitask learning for
example if you just do a a uniform prior
over the tasks and some of them did
quite badly and of course it's just a
balancing thing because you know you're
you're kind of under training on some
tasks and over training on other tasks
and they came up with a temperature
parameter to kind of you know to wait
the relevant tasks as a function of how
much contribution they had but it's not
just the difference between the tasks
it's also the concept of the the
unsupervised training objective
dominating the downstream tasks so
there's quite a balance I think the most
important thing is the the kind of
transfer rate between all of the
different training objectives hmm
yeah it's cool to see like not cool but
you see that same phenomenon of like
class and balance like where you have
way more like dogs and cats than
and then also in this task framework
it's also like yes it's definitely
interesting like the class and balance
problem and then seeing it on the tasks
level also but yeah I mean you would
think that like the text prefix would be
able to like do the like I guess that's
kind of why the conditional computation
thing is so interesting if you can have
this special like sparse routing that
comes from the task embedding in might
that might be the best way to overcome
like class and balance it cause some
balance tasking balance or maybe like
kind of also it's kind of also like
catastrophic forgetting and continual
learning in a way I think like a little
bit and that I think the latest solution
to that from the Jeff clean paper is is
like neuromodulation and sort of another
kind of sparse routing I think just like
that I'm not exactly sure what happens
in that paper but yes definitely
interesting to think of the composition
of the multitask datasets in the size of
them absolutely I mean that's pretty
much the paper to be honest but I think
it was it was really really good just to
explore you know if I change this and if
I change this what makes the biggest
difference and clearly when when you
look at the history of all of the kind
of the papers let's say in question
answering over the last few years it was
the Bur paper that really gave us the
significant boost and since then we've
probably got you know another ten points
worth of improvement but is balancing
out but when you look at a kind of two
year time horizon it was this transfer
learning and maybe all transfer learning
means is training for longer on more
data but that was what gave us that the
biggest improvement okay I mean just
another comment that might be worth
making is just how this is democratizing
it's so easy now just a download a pre
train model just this unified t5 model
that we're talking about I mean you can
download it they've published it online
or you can train it again yourself and
you can just do really sophisticated
translation just I guess the point I'm
trying to make is a few years ago and if
you wanted to do really
good speech recognition or translation
you couldn't do it yourself you had to
use the Microsoft or Google cloud
platform you know that it's called
cognitive services on Azure because
these are things that it was just
accepted that you couldn't do it
yourself because you didn't have enough
data you didn't have a good enough model
you had to pay for it now it's really
becoming quite democratized yeah I think
it's also like yeah like you can just
form your own data set and then be like
answer these questions about it and
there's I also think it's so important
to remember that like the MTN MT DNN
like multistage thing to where like if
you can get like say you want to get all
of the deep learning papers and make a
data set of that like before you start
labeling it you can also do this self
supervised learning on that data too and
have that pipeline show us something is
yeah I mean and that may be like in
another way to think about it is why is
language different because a high
quality language data set apparently as
thirty five gigabytes
that's nothing whereas facial
recognition that seems different
you know the google face net paper
they've trained it on about twenty six
million faces and that's why it works so
well and that has incredible value I
mean I wouldn't be able to download that
from Google I mean if I did it would be
very very valuable so it's almost as if
language is now becoming more
democratized than vision yeah it's just
a more compressed representation right I
think we've just not figured out yet
four images how to compress how to
compress them in a way so that we can
reconstruct them but ultimately all you
care about is what ends up in your brain
right so so for language we've we found
this good notion that we can encapsulate
the sound waves in just words but I just
don't I think for images we just have
not yet done this and maybe in the
future once we figure that out the the
datasets might just become smaller in
size the question is how much
informative content is there maybe one
way of looking at it though is that and
because language and vision are both
there in their unstruck
data it's in the unstructured domain but
if you think about it vision is much
more unstructured than language language
is actually very structured isn't it you
know you have atomic tokens and you can
model very very clear that sort of
relationships between where they appear
and it's one-dimensional so maybe that's
the reason why you actually need much
less you know pre training data for
language as you do for vision yeah
possibly yeah I mean that there's
there's it you only have to kind of
learn the grammar of a language right to
to make sentences at least but in order
to learn what what are natural images
you have to like learn correlations
between all the pixels and no one tells
you what's what's good and what's not
right I'm not sure maybe it's also
because vision is just like almost like
a 2d image of the actual 3d world with
objects so it's sort of a position yeah
of something
um yeah I'm not not sure I'm I have
another questions what what do you think
how far will this this we encode
everything as text this task go because
I'm pretty sure if I were to produce
something like a chatbot or something
like an assistant you know like an Alexa
I would just hard code all the single
commands and that would work much better
for now right that's actually a really
interesting point because if you you
know there is that famous chat bot from
Microsoft Cote or Tao and if they you
should be incredibly careful releasing
anything into the world which learns and
which isn't explicitly programmed and
not even talking about learning right
it's just like do you do you train it
with this notion of I'm going to really
understand what the human wants in like
a deep learning kind of way or you know
if I were to do this I would try to
understand what it means and then just
reg X match to my predefined lists of
tasks that it can do well I think we
define the reg X list to be so
challenging like if we're like on lift
customer service and you and I are both
frustrated about like the map is made an
error I think we're both going to
describe our problems so differently and
natural language that that's what the
problem and then so then I guess it's
like this idea of like fast adaptation
it needs to quickly adapt to how Conor
describes his frustration with the map
yeah tend to how quick and then quickly
adapt to how Yannick is gonna describe
his frustration with the customer
service so so yeah I think like that
domain adaptation and like getting
quickly to the new domain is going to be
the key thing that makes this applicable
I think there's something interesting
here though which is that first of all
people think that chat BOTS are all
about AI and they're really not they are
just a user interface and they are best
constructed with static rules the only
natural language processing that you get
is things like intent recognition so
what do I want to do because if you
think about it and if you did have some
kind of an unstructured output I mean
imagine you plug the GPT model into your
chat bot and you could say to the chapel
how are you feeling today and the GPT
model will say I'm feeling great things
but what value does that have it's
completely useless and it's also
unquantifiable if I wanted to test this
thing if I'm releasing this thing in my
production system and I wanted to write
tests and I wanted to understand what it
was doing it's just it's completely
useless I've got no idea but what it
yeah what if it was like it was pre
trained on like the chat bot it's like a
chat bot and then you can fine-tune it
somehow and like all the deep learning
papers and then you can ask it questions
about that it would be sort of
interesting that would be sort of
interesting I just I just find this
notion of you know formulating the task
as text and then what what this paper
doesn't do is then how how then can you
do yes something like the meta learning
that the Conor said is quick at can you
can you throw if you do this enough can
you throw a task at it that it's never
seen in that form given the textual
instructions right and then I'm thinking
back I've seen a presentation by a
Richards soccer a while ago of
Salesforce where he pretty much proposed
the same thing but he said all of NLP
should this could be question-answering
so you always have a question and the
context and
he he had this this also this notion of
you can output text to answer the
question so you can frame something like
next sentence prediction or you can do
something like sentiment analysis by
simply outputting text right but he also
had this notion of pointer networks and
these I find have just gone down I don't
know if they don't work or if they're
just not hip but he always uses these or
his group always use this pointer
networks where he says you can either
output text or you can point to
something in the context or in the
questions and here's that here's the
answer and I think you know think
because they already formulated this
kind of all of NLP should be in this one
task structure very similar like here
maybe we're ready for a return like for
a resurrection of the pointer Network
here just interesting parallels it can
remind you like multi-hop question
answering like that kind of idea where
it's like you need to say like you know
you need to answer your question such
that you want to go and ask two more
questions to like better answer the
question yeah that context free question
answering is one of the key things that
they claim this t5 model does well is
that you can be like when was World War
two or you know any question and it just
knows it because it's memorized it yeah
yeah of course but the GPT - was that
was also its thing right they but
they're they didn't fine-tune they just
pre trained the language model and then
they posed the question and magically
that the answer came out and just right
because it was in the training data
somewhere yeah I love this parallel
between in in the olden days we used to
have knowledge graphs that were
explicitly computed and we would say in
that knowledge graph that Barack Obama
is 45 years old and the thing is it was
so ownerís to build up the knowledge in
the knowledge graphs and and the
information was often conflicting so
they used to write unit tests you know
which we check for logical equivalence
and actually that's happening in
language models as well so you know my
friend Marco Rubio he
this concept of coming up with no
semantically equivalent adversarial
examples or logical tests so what he
might do is he might ask the question
how many boots are there in this image
and the answer would be 3 and then the
logical consistency question would be
are there any boots in this image and
you expect it to be yes
and you can use all of these things
possibly to generate an adversarial
examples which you can then use to you
know to pre train or to fine-tune the
model or you could potentially use it as
a way to say no I don't like this model
I'm not going to put it into production
but I'm quite interested in in this
engineering reality because we have
these unstructured models and coming up
with some non interactive way to reason
about its behavior is really interesting
but even humans are terrible at this
like humans would fail these unit tests
so hard because I don't ever so there is
this this thing in like personalities
science called the the Big Five
personality tests right and it's kind of
statistically derived and so on and if
you it's a self-report test and if you
fill that out they would always ask you
the same thing in two different ways
they'll be like I often feel sad and
then it would be like I don't often feel
not sad or they do it smarter but still
and then like the times the amount of
times where this number isn't the
negative of this number is just
astounding it was like hey human you
said you always feel sad but here you
said you're mostly happy what's going on
you know what's even worse so when I
applied for my current job they gave me
these silly psychometric profiles and
and they they said I was only an X out
of X on this dimension and I said why is
that and he said you took ten
milliseconds too long to answer the
question
[Laughter]
crazy maybe maybe these I mean I see
where these kind of tests are going but
it's it's at some point it becomes more
becomes more a question of the tester
right of how well the tester how well
these things are really logically
equivalent
all right because language is just so
subtle and the the the boundaries to
things like sarcasm
you know the boundaries to things like
hyperbole and are so narrow sometimes
that it is super hard to write this
procedurally again if we could write the
these things procedurally we could solve
the problem yeah but again this is
something where we have the potential
because the reason why words net for
example I mean that was also a knowledge
graph and it was very brittle and it
didn't get updated very often and it
didn't know colloquialism so it didn't
know that this word means something
different where we are but possibly the
composability and distributed nature of
deep learning architectures would allow
us to start with a kind of pre trained
base model and then potentially and have
a high velocity model which is kind of
learning colloquialisms that are
relevant to me yeah definitely
well guys I think we've come to the end
of the show but it's been emotional I
just want to address maybe viewers that
we just were trying different things so
you last week we had an author on this
was more like interview style the week
before we had like many different people
we're in a field where none of us was
really you know well versed we just kind
of someone had something to say at some
point so if you know we don't know
ourselves what's what is the best and
the most interesting so we're looking
very much for feedback on what people
like and what is interesting and what
isn't and should we you know be super
prepared and very technical for people
that know everything or are most people
like wealth you talk about things that I
don't even understand you should
introduce the the concepts first so I'm
just
kind of an appeal to the listeners or
viewers to leave us comments poke us
with planes and remember to hit that
subscribe button and the notification
bell cos if you don't we will be
seriously unimpressed alright these are